hey youtubers is Charlie yesterday
during my Game of Thrones video I asked
you all to submit questions for a new
Q&A originally I meant to do weekly Q&A
is whenever it went off the air but I
got so many requests for Teen Wolf this
summer that it made my Monday nights
just a complete nightmare I am moving to
a new apartment in the next two weeks
and quitting my job to be a YouTube
weirdo full-time so it's gonna be a
little crazy for a little bit longer but
pretty soon you'll start seeing more
cuties and more bonus videos so it'll
get a lot better if you're just finding
me for the first time and you have
absolutely no idea what the hell I'm
talking about I do weekly Game of
Thrones videos I even do a weekly Song
of Ice and Fire book giveaway so be sure
to subscribe to get everything
george RR martin just went to the
Edinburgh Book Festival and there was
supposed to be a live stream but I have
not found a video link if he says
anything interesting about Windsor
winter I'll totally include it in my
next bonus video so let's answer some
questions most of these are just sand
snakes and season five related stuff
from my last video so question number
one Jon Targaryen asks will you do a
winds of winter predictions video so I
totally love trying to figure things out
and piece together clues and do
predictions videos but because total
book sales is like a fraction of the
audience for the show I try not to do
too many spoiler videos
I think George RR Martin's total book
sales as of last year was like 28
million and this year on the show
average viewership for each episode was
like 10 million people so it's crazy
as a compromise I just try to do big
prediction videos every once in a while
even for the show I'm sure all of you at
some point have seen like an all caps
rant
whenever someone sees a spoiler they
didn't want to see Martin actually
withdrew from writing anything for the
show to focus on writing wins a winter
or finish it they haven't announced an
official release date but in my fantasy
he finishes it in time for the season 5
finale in June 2015 or at least by
November 2015 so I will start doing more
book specific videos for that whenever
we get closer I don't have a specific
date in mind for whatever my next winds
of winter videos gonna be but I do pull
people on Twitter and Facebook whenever
I'm thinking about new topics to do week
to week so if you're not following there
you can find links for that at the
bottom of the description question
number two Alec connage our asks do you
have a favorite character do you want to
see on the Iron Throne so I don't think
that I've said this before but lately I
started to think about the Iron Throne
as a very non desirable thing
like I've stopped thinking about it as a
goal that someone should have think
about it this way the crown is
hopelessly in debt
everyone at court is a liar or a thief
and all the really interesting people
that you really want to hang out with
have been scattered to the four winds if
I were on the show and I wanted to be
like a really cool person I would try to
restore the supernatural balance in the
world there may only be a handful of
characters in the books that have their
minds on that the rest are all focused
on the here and now like gaining control
of a single city or a single Kingdom in
the case of Westeros the Iron Throne is
more of a symbol it's like a really
shiny toy to distract people from the
real problems Robert Baratheon for
instance won it and it totally ended up
killing him so not all characters should
consider it a really viable goal if
you're someone more practical like bran
and you like the simple things in life
then all you really care about is having
sex with your new wife flawless in your
brand new castle myself I tend to think
more like maester aemon he had a much
broader perspective on what's happening
in the world just because he's seen so
much of history I actually have a lot of
interesting thoughts about him at the
end of Dance with Dragons for anyone
that wants to talk about it in the
comments on to question number three its
Lunas asks do you think that they'll
show big non-book scenes like the white
Walker scene in Episode four so you're
asking if the show is gonna do things
that were in the books but the George R
Martin just didn't write about yes I
definitely think they're gonna do more
of that they said that they're gonna go
even further off-book for a number of
reasons which means there's an even
better chance they'll include something
that they think is really important
regardless of whether or not George our
Martin chose to include it in the books
I think a really good example would be
showing us the creation of Robert strong
in the books it's just implied who he is
and where he came from
Qyburn slab underneath the black cells
or they'll show us more Chi burns black
magic or what the characters on the show
think is black magic he's kind of like
the dr. Frankenstein of the series
blending the science of the maesters
with black magic necromancy I'm
definitely hoping to learn more about
him during winds of winter speaking of
which I also think that more of the
non-book scenes from the lands of always
winter will happen but not a lot there's
no way they're gonna go a whole year
without doing another big white Walker
scene question number four Josephine
Swift asks what do you think they'll do
with the Ironborn characters so I think
the show is just gonna narrow its focus
to the characters that has already spent
a lot of time on
beyond for all intents and purposes is
the Ironborn storyline even though last
season yara said that he was not her
brother anymore just because he'd been
consumed by the reek persona the
Ironborn aren't completely gone I just
think they'll take the Victarion in your
on moments and give them to Yara like
whenever they cut out a big storm and
gave his story to Gendry I think that's
what they'll do with the uncles I know
everyone's really bummed and they want
to see him but unless they cast them by
october/november there's no way that
they're gonna make it into season five
if it does end up going down that way
they'll prejudice give your on story in
book five to Yara and just send her
wherever he ends up going I know it's a
really big storyline they could end up
doing the Kingsmoot and just truncate it
just to Center it on her I am still
planning on doing a bonus video just for
the Greyjoy uncles because they are
really interesting characters and they
have big parts so whenever I do that
I'll just be sure to specifically say
what I think that the show's gonna
change from the books question number
five Nick Baba asks what do you think
they'll do with the Dornish master plan
given that a lot of the involved
characters have not been cast so if
you've not heard about the Dornish
master plan it's just a plan that Oberyn
and his brother Prince Doran enacted
whenever their sister Elia was killed
during Robert's rebellion it's all about
getting revenge on the Lannisters I
think the best way I can explain it
without going into crazy spoilers is
that the show will just simplify
everything just make it way more linear
so this far it seems like they cut out
Aryan and Quentin so what they'll
probably do is just give Aryans plot to
Obara or another character and the
pluggy of Quentin's part to trystane
they'll just cut out the whole marriage
part of the master plan and promise
trystane to the person that Quentin was
going to marry are going to try to marry
at least I think I mentioned it during
mice and snakes video but I think
they're gonna expand the Marcela plot
they're just gonna make that bigger
Christine is betrothed to Marcela that's
not gonna change but they'll probably
tease the Quentin plot behind the
Lannisters backs I don't think that
they're gonna send trystane on the trip
that Quentin took I think that they'll
just tease it in some sort of letter if
that totally sounds confusing I'll
clarify in the comments but essentially
they're just gonna narrow it all down to
a couple of characters and still do the
Merciless stuff but on to question
number six flying spectacle says once
they're done with the show they should
totally do another big historical event
like Robert's rebellion the Andal
invasion etc yes all great suggestions
yes HBO is definitely developing another
game of Thrones spin-off type show right
now the show is a huge deal at HBO this
year
became their most-watched series of all
time meaning it's making them more money
than anything next to their sporting
events or at least driving subscriptions
they don't advertise so profits are
typically measured in premium
subscribers it's the same deal AMC with
Walking Dead it's so profitable for AMC
that they're gonna continue to do
Walking Dead content till the end of
time HBO has already signed a
development deal with George art Martin
they did it I think during season 1 it
was to start a spin-off show they
haven't said anything about it or made
any announcements since then but as long
as Martin gives HBO the rights to future
content of his they'll keep doing it
either as a TV series a miniseries or TV
movies so do not worry there will be
guaranteed Game of Thrones main series
content for at least four more years
after that it'll either be a miniseries
or TV movie who knows or just a regular
old spinoff series question number 7
Albert a asks do you think that they're
going to take out Jamie's story in book
4 or just do it later so if you watch
the spoilery part of the sand snakes
video I posted essentially he and bran
are just going somewhere else
the pride just cut out all the river
runs stuff completely the King's Landing
stuff he's involved in I think is gonna
stay the same just because it's a pretty
big deal moving on to question number 8
Captain Jack asks that's an awesome name
was the picture of Bradley James a
coincidence or did my spoiler casting
dreams just come true so that was
totally just me using a picture of
someone that I thought looked like Harry
Harding that happens all the time
there's like a billion characters in A
Song of Ice and Fire but there's not
pictures for most of them so whenever
you talk about a historical figure that
there's no media for it you just have to
get creative if I were like a
halfway-decent artist I would totally
just try and make my own drawings but I
am the shittiest artist in the world I
suppose there's always a chance that
Brad James could make it on the show but
usually they cast lesser-known actors
Jonathan Pryce is the exception this
season just because he's a really big
actor it gives you an idea for how much
weight that they're going to be placing
on the high Sparrow that's who he's
playing if anyone hasn't seen the
casting video Jonathan Pryce is playing
the high Sparrow but on to question
number nine bh0 6 asks with the death of
JJ Murphy what do you think they're
going to do up at the wall so for anyone
who hasn't seen the news in Akron 8 JJ
Murphy just died after filming like four
days on Game of Thrones the character he
was playing was Dennis Mouser he was
going to be the big
candidate to succeed jr. Mormon as the
next Lord Commander the producer said
that they're not gonna recast the role
but they'd only filmed for about four
days so they still have scenes left to
finish with them what they'll probably
do is just write around it and speed up
to you know whoever the next floor
commander is gonna be if you've read the
books just use spoiler tags whenever
you're commenting about it but the
probably just gonna speed that up and
last question number 10 Jeeves machine
asks Charlie never replies to me and it
makes me sad
I am totally sad that you feel like I
don't comment back to you but you
actually have replies turned off and it
brings up a really interesting thing
that I don't get to talk about very
often if you look at your comment here
it means no one can reply to you
otherwise the reply button would appear
like the green mailer here below you so
really big requests from me to you guys
please turn replies on so we can all
talk to each other remember please be
nice I will delete troll comments if
some of you are having problems
commenting it might be because you
haven't found your channel to a Google+
account new comments won't work if you
haven't done that yet and no one will be
able to reply to you so please do that
so other people can talk to you also
second really big thing please upload an
avatar I think like half the people's
questions that I picked on this did not
have avatars I always loved to show off
your faces in my videos whenever you
leave comments that I really like but I
can't do that if you don't have an
avatar if you're not sure how to upload
an avatar because the new Google+ thing
you uploaded on Google+ and it'll just
automatically syndicate to YouTube
channel so thank you so much everyone
for submitting questions and once I
moved to my new apartment in a couple
weeks I will totally do a room tour it's
just gonna give me an opportunity to
make all this look just a little bit
nicer it'll be a little bit more fun my
next bonus video like I said yesterday
will totally be for the faceless men but
real quick the winner of this week's
book giveaway is time vampire 83 you get
your pick of any of Martin's books of
short stories paperback or kindle I will
message you on your channel for details
so be sure to check your inbox there was
a new Doctor Who trailer the drop that
I'll be doing a video for tomorrow but
in the meantime you can click here to
learn about all eight of the sand snakes
and you can click here to learn about
the big changes that season 5 is making
to the books thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow high
fives